The anime caused a social phenomenon.
It is a reboot that hardcore fans have been waiting for a long time.
Please do enjoy this anime together with the movie series.
Ta-da!
Hi, it's N-ko!
This week's The N-ko Show has started!
Today, I'd like to talk a bit about
the American anime I watched when I was little.
Cartoon Network, Nickelodeon, and Disney Channel are the three main channels
that broadcast anime for children.
And there's another one, similar to Japan's NHK,
which has educational shows. I watched that as well.
Among them, I absolutely loved...
if I were to give an example of anime streamed on Netflix,
it was AVATAR, AIRBENDER.
I absolutely loved it.
American anime is similar to Japanese anime.
Each episode is a complete story,
but they somehow develop into a big story.
You can enjoy it if you miss some episodes,
but you'll also enjoy it if you watch it every week.
Many anime are like that.
Well then, let's start this week's The N-ko Show!
I will share my recommendations based on my personal preference again.
This is the theme.
Try to expand your world!
Overseas anime you will surely get hooked on!
Many anime originate in Japan,
but many interesting anime are being made all over the world now!
This time, if you haven't watched overseas anime before,
and if you don't know them at all,
I'll recommend some to you.
First, it's this anime.
WAKFU.
This is a television anime produced in France,
it's a fantasy anime based on its original video game.
Yugo, whose blue hood is his trademark,
belongs to the species closest to the gods who created the world,
Eliatrope, which is a rare species.
A catastrophe occurred in the world shortly after he was born,
so he was adopted by
a man called Alibert, together with the message he was entrusted with.
Yugo lives peacefully with Alibert,
but a certain incident causes his special power to awaken.
When Alibert sees Yugo's special power,
he recalls the message he was entrusted with
and tells Yugo to go on a journey to look for his real family.
And the story goes on.
That's the abstract of the story.
I especially recommend it to people who are used to watching Japanese anime.
The cute and adorable character designs are excellent.
The illustrations of battle scenes are also overwhelming.
It's easy to enter the world of this anime.
Many anime fans call this a great anime, so please do watch it.
Next, it's this anime.
VOLTRON: LEGENDARY DEFENDER.
It was co-produced by America and Korea.
Lion robots are piloted by five warriors, the Paladins,
and they combine to form the strongest warrior, Voltron.
The five Paladins use it to confront
the Galra Empire, which is a threat to the universe,
in this grand space robot action anime.
It was originally a reboot of the popular American anime, VOLTRON,
which cause a social phenomenon mainly among
children in America at that time.
So it is a reboot that hardcore fans have been waiting for a long time.
Of course, even people who don't know the social phenomenon at that time
can thoroughly enjoy this anime,
whose action scenes are the best!
As a matter of fact,
DreamWorks Animation is part of the production team.
They've produced prominent series,
like the KUNG FU PANDA series and the SHREK series.
Their overwhelming abilities of illustration and representation are impeccable,
and you'll surely get caught up in the anime.
I especially recommend this anime to robot fans,
so please do watch it.
Next, it's this anime.
THE MIDNIGHT GOSPEL.
Spacecaster, Clancy, uses a simulator
to go to parallel universes that are in various crises of destruction
and interviews the people there.
It's an anime produced by America and each episode is independent.
It is difficult to tell you the abstract of the anime's throughline,
but as to the most special feature of this anime,
the stories were written based on podcast interviews by
Mr. Duncan Trussell, who plays the protagonist, Clancy.
Mr. Pendleton Ward, the original creator of this anime,
had the idea of animating the contents of Mr. Trussell's podcast interviews
and they produced this anime.
The script is good,
the drawings are psychedelic, and it's a bit grotesque,
but the contents are humorous,
and the anime is just like a podcast you can watch.
It goes beyond the limits of anime so far.
Everything depicted is new,
so you'll surely get addicted to it after you watch it once.
Next, it's this anime.
RICK AND MORTY.
Rick, a drunk genius scientist,
brings his grandson Morty along
to travel to various dimensions and worlds.
It's a comedy about the troubles that occur at their destinations.
Like the typical anime produced in America,
it has deformed character designs,
and it's full of black humor with an edge of satire.
So I recommend the anime to all age groups, from adults to children.
How Morty is at the mercy of Rick's craziness
is one of the great charms of this anime.
Typical American comedies
often turn movies or actual incidents into funny parodies
and present them in a comical way.
But in many cases, we don't know where the stories come from, right?
In this anime, most of the ideas are derived from pop culture.
Famous scenes that everyone would have seen
are turned into parodies everywhere,
so even if you don't know much about movies and anime,
you'll find this anime funny.
I recommend it to people who want to casually enjoy overseas anime.
The last one is this.
JURASSIC WORLD CAMP CRETACEOUS.
This is a computer graphics anime produced by DreamWorks Animation.
It is a sci-fi anime that depicts the world of the famous movies,
the JURASSIC PARK series.
The stage is the one also featured in the movies,
Isla Nublar, the island where dinosaurs live.
When six children go to the campsite,
can they run away from the dinosaurs that are out of control,
and escape from the island?
This is the abstract.
Surprisingly, this is the first anime produced
as based on the JURASSIC PARK series.
Besides anime fans,
movie fans should check out this anime too.
It's linked to incidents that happen in the movies,
and it's closely related to the incidents portrayed in
JURASSIC WORLD, which was released in 2015.
Please do enjoy this anime together with the movie series.
All the anime I introduced today are unique,
and you will surely get hooked on them.
Please do watch them.
That's it for Weekly Favorites.
Please tell N-ko.
This time,
I'd also like our viewers to introduce anime I haven't watched to me.
This is the introduction we received.
It was produced by TRIGGER, wasn't it?
It was an OVA, a movie, and an anime series.
So it was made into a television anime after the films, right?
The television anime has 25 episodes in total
and was broadcast for two seasons.
Oh, isn't that Megumi Han-san?
It's fair to say that Megumi Han-san is Netflix's voice actress.
Sorry, I'm going to mention another anime.
There are elements of HARRY POTTER,
OJAMAJO DOREMI,
and MY HERO ACADEMIA, in this anime.
I heard many rumors in 2017 that this anime was amazing,
but for some reason, I didn't see it.
I missed the chance to watch it.
Like the way the broomsticks are shaped,
the anime's world view is unique,
and the costume of each character has particular details.
I can feel that the anime's world is elaborate just by looking at its website.
I do want to watch it.
Thank you for recommending it.
That's it for Please Tell N-ko.
N-ko's Q & A section!
I will answer your questions again this week.
Let's start.
This is the first question.
Hello, Maestro Lunar, I love you.
Maestro Lunar-san, please leave a comment.
And thank you, Maestro Lunar-san's friend.
Lol...
I'm rooting for you from Australia!
I'm looking forward to your next video, please do your best.
Thank you.
I've never been to Australia,
so I'd like to go to Australia
and enjoy the high-quality forbs with the person who left the comment.
It is N-ko,
and the other is "poop."
I don't deny that their pronunciations are similar,
but when you say it in English, it's N-ko.
N, ko.
Okay, next question.
"N-ko, thank you for telling us about anime.
Your voice is very beautiful and relaxing."
"N-ko, thank you for telling us about anime,
Thanks for your comment.
Thank you for typing it out in the Japanese romaji.
I did my best to speak in Spanish, was that okay?
Please do get relaxed.
Okay, next question.
Well, I really kind of want to play APEX and do live streaming.
I'll do my best
so that I can play and show you my clumsy APEX playing skills someday.
I'll do my best. Thank you.
Thank you again for your various questions.
I'm still waiting for you to send me your questions.
That's it for N-ko's Q & A.
The N-ko Show! It's now time to say goodbye.
I have introduced many overseas anime to you today,
and I enjoyed it a lot.
Like anime produced by France and America,
or anime co-produced with Korea,
I think this has been an episode that can make you feel
the love for anime from all over the world.
Let's meet again next time!
See you!